much like Game of Thrones before it
HBO's Westworld is an elaborate epic
puzzle box of a production that serves
in the end as an excuse to explore
something much smaller and much more
important character this is why despite
the sweeping vistas what holds
everything else up are the conversations
how they're written and how they're
acted today I want to take a look at one
conversation featuring the great Anthony
Hopkins specifically I want to examine
how Hopkins acts the seen how he
elevates every line of dialogue to a
hypnotically interesting level you'll
imagine I've gone mad lost my way we're
simply concerned about the extent of the
changes you're making you want to
protect the legacy my legacy
okay the background of the scene is that
Teresa : and operations manager of the
West World theme park is trying to stop
or at least stall the creation of Robert
for Anthony Hopkins new storyline for
the guests a storyline that is generally
wreaking chaos on things to the point of
worrying the parks finance ears it's
clear that Teresa feels that Ford's
undertaking is just too risky
but instead of forthrightly telling him
so she puts things in euphemistic terms
you want to protect the legacy my legacy
okay that pause is fully seven seconds
long and it is amazing after reacting in
disbelief at such a shameless euphemism
Hopkins in silent cycles through a few
emotions first disbelief then a
consideration of the words for a split
second at their face value maybe he
should safeguard his legacy maybe he
shouldn't be so ambitious at his age
then a smile and the scene will feature
several shades of smile this one is kind
as kind as can be in the face of what he
considers to be an attack one that
insults his intelligence as he looks
down and chuckles the smile seems to
acquire some suppressed anger he can
only bear to look at her in quick
glances as he composes himself then he
fires back an antagonistic remark
you don't like this place very much do
you I've seen many of you come and go
over the years and I can tell the ones
who enjoy the time here the ones who
don't what's impressive here is how
Hopkins breaks down the dialogue as
written in interviews Hopkins has
described how he reads scripts 200 times
or so to the point where the dialogue is
lodged in his brain then he steps away
lets it gestate in his mind and when he
arrives on set he relaxes himself and
let the pot plays for you by having such
a command over the words Hopkins is able
to modulate the tempo of their delivery
to get the most out of it this sentence
for example is sped through I've seen
many of you come and go over the is as
is the first part of the next sentence
until a pause after who drawing out the
word enjoy which falls right back into a
speedy delivery almost slipping over the
words until the final - which coupled
with eye contact slow down to function
as an accusation I've seen many of you
come and go over the years and I can
tell the ones who enjoy the time and
ones who don't I admire it the audacity
of it a small interjection but see how
he opens up like a flower from the
hunched position he releases a little
tension to receive the compliment great
touch I came here once as a child with
my parents I think we even sat at this
table when I started working here I
realized this place wasn't something I
would enjoy and then we get a second
interjection when his suspicions are
confirmed followed by a hunching again
and a deflated neck then from this
position Hopkins launches into his key
speech in the beginning I imagined
things would be perfectly balanced even
had a bet with my partner Arnold to that
effect he made a hundred hopeful
storylines of course almost no one took
us up on them I lost the bet
Arnold always held a somewhat dim view
of people he preferred the hosts he
begged me not to let you people in the
money men tell us
okay we're about to learn that this
whole meeting is a threat set up by
Hopkins and to signal that Hopkins
incrementally dials up the Menace across
three terms that specify who he's
threatening you people money men Delos
listen to it again he begged me not to
let you people in the money men tell us
but I told maybe find that you didn't
understand what you were paying for it's
not a business venture not a theme park
but in the entire world
we designed every inch of it
every blade of grass
and here we were cards you
Maylee August's watching this the first
time it was here that it struck me how
crucial Ford's personality is to the
functioning of the series I mean West
world is in many ways a ridiculous idea
both as a theme park and as a TV show to
work the conceit had to be mapped
reflected justified in the complex
desires and ambitions of its creators
the writers have achieved that in Fort
but it's Hopkins who really brings these
things to life and how did that work out
for Ronald sadly he lost his perspective
he went mad I haven't as you will know I
have always seen things very clearly the
threat now explicit Hopkins colors the
rest of the scene with a sinister glee
this is the table i sat on with my
parents we know everything about our
guests don't be as we know ever think
about our employees from here on out he
presses his advantage not with force but
with comfort with a smile no longer
needing to convince Teresa of his
dominance Hopkins dances into different
attitudes for a couple of seconds before
falling back into that smile like right
here where he's matter of fact we know
everything about our guests don't they
as we know ever think about our
employees or hear where he's concerned I
do hope he will be careful with Vinod or
hear where he's genuinely caring as his
eyes wander off for a moment - he has a
sensitive disposition
the producers of this show are smart to
keep the camera fixed on Hopkins face
his ability learned across many decades
to convey such a web of feeling and
suggests such a universe of feeling
within about a character we know little
about expands the entire shows range and
strengthens its persuasive power as a
piece of art that's what a great actor
can do he can give words and images or a
short scene like this a volcanic energy
it was a quiet look in Anthony Hopkins
hands in his eyes West world isn't just
a reflection of its creators personality
it's a self-portrait you can tell the
board that my narrative will be
completed on time and it won't be a
retrospective as I'm sure you all fear
I'm not the sentimental type
[Music]
hey everybody there is a new nerdwriter
video every Wednesday so if you click
right there you'll subscribe to this
channel and get all the videos sorry
I've been so irregular with my posting
recently I've been in Italy it's been
crazy but also been writing a couple
speeches for the Singapore Writers
Festival which I'll be at in a couple
weeks and so that's been taking a lot of
my time I have to shout out a channel
that I really love called wisecrack they
do video essays like me 8-bit philosophy
earthling cinema stuff like that they
just did something on Bojack horseman
which is a show i love and the video was
great too so I'll link that below check
that out thanks guys for watching I'll
see everybody next Wednesday hopefully